♪♪
-Let's get to the news.
President Biden said on Friday
that he is "convinced"
that Russian
President Vladimir Putin
has already made the decision
to invade Ukraine.
Putin reportedly made
the decision somewhere around
his ninth birthday.
[ Laughter ]
He was a fun kid.
President Biden held a meeting
of the National Security Council
yesterday
to discuss the situation
in Ukraine,
where they told him
it's basically like
washing down Taco Bell
with an iced coffee --
we know something's going
to happen.
We just don't know when
and how bad.
[ Laughter ]
It was announced yesterday
that Britain's Queen Elizabeth
has tested positive
for the coronavirus.
Wow. You couldn't wait
just a few more weeks
to hit the club.
[ Laughter ]
The National Archives
confirmed last week
that former President Trump
improperly took
classified material
from the White House
to his Mar-A-Lago club.
Also, all the copper wiring.
[ Laughter ]
Ahead of President Biden's State
of the Union address next week,
authorities in Washington, D.C.
will reportedly put
additional fencing
around the Capitol,
which is actually all you need
to know
about the state of the union.
[ Laughter ]
Rudy Giuliani is set to appear
in an upcoming episode
of the singing competition show
"The Masked Singer."
I knew that couldn't be
his real face.
[ Laughter ]
Former President Trump
yesterday launched
his new social media app,
Truth Social.
It's expected to revolutionize
the way Americans
have their data stolen.
[ Laughter ]
According to a new survey,
22% of Americans said
that they are very interested
in being president of the
United States for one day.
"When can you start?"
asked one man.
[ Laughter ]
"'Cause I'd love if somebody
would jump in today."
[ Laughter and applause ]
A dog in California was recently
reunited with its family
after it was missing
for 12 years.
Or, in the dog's mind,
a couple hours.
[ Laughter ]
"Everybody chill
the [bleep] out."
[ Laughter ]
"I went outside."
AT&T is set tomorrow
to shut down
its 3G cellular network.
As opposed to their 4G network,
which shuts down whenever.
[ Laughter ]
And, finally,
an athlete from Finland
told reporters over the weekend
that, after competing
in the men's 50-kilometer
cross-country ski race
at the Beijing Games,
his penis was
"a little bit frozen."
[ Laughter ]
Though, just because he needed
an excuse after he was caught
"warming it up."
[ Laughter ]
♪♪
Russian President Vladimir Putin
yesterday
ordered troops into separatist
regions of Eastern Ukraine
and said they were
"peacekeepers."
Specifically,
they're keeping this piece.
[ Laughter ]
President Biden is set
to impose sanctions
after Putin ordered troops
into Ukraine.
From now on, Russia doesn't
get the new Wordle until noon.
[ Laughter ]
It's very easy.
Russian Wordle's very easy,
'cause it's always "Putin."
[ Laughter ]
Senate Judiciary
Chair Dick Durbin
said yesterday
that his first call
when Supreme Court
Justice Stephen Breyer
announced his retirement
was to his committee's
top Republican, Chuck Grassley.
And Grassley's first call
was to,
I don't know,
Alexander Graham Bell?
[ Laughter ]
According to the latest numbers,
more than half of unemployed
American men in their 30s
have criminal records.
Also vinyl ones.
[ Laughter ]
The social media platform
Snapchat
unveiled a new feature last week
that allows users to share their
real-time location with friends.
You can learn more about it
in an upcoming episode
of "Dateline."
[ Laughter ]
"Snapchat wasn't the only thing
that disappeared that day."
[ Laughter ]
A passable Keith Morrison.
According to a new survey,
59% of Americans prefer
for toilet paper to be hung
so that the next sheet
comes from over the roll.
And somehow that 59% are all
married to the other 41%.
[ Laughter ]
The New York Times published
an op-ed yesterday titled...
And I think I speak for everyone
when I say...
[ Laughter ]
And finally,
according to a new survey,
40% of Americans said that they
don't enjoy gossiping at all
and then added,
"But you know who does?
Jessica, Jessica."
[ Laughter ]
And that -- Oh, that's some
really good gossip.
Look at them.
[ Laughter ]
If somebody is whispering
in your ear,
you can't make that face.
[ Laughter ]
It's like, "I have a secret."
It's like...
Like, you can't do that
at a barbecue.
And then everyone's like, "What
were you guys talking about?"
"Um, the potato salad."
♪♪
President Biden has reportedly
met with
at least three Supreme Court
candidates in the hopes
that one of them will prove
worthy to join the elite group
of the most respected legal
minds in the country
and Brett Kavanaugh.
[ Laughter ]
President Biden spoke yesterday
from the East Room
about the Ukraine crisis
and said,
"As Russia contemplates
its next move,
we have our next move
prepared as well."
Spoken like a man
on the fifth row of Wordle
with only two yellow squares.
[ Laughter ]
I mean, Wordle is hot.
Wordle is hot to the touch base.
[ Imitates sizzling ]
[ Laughter ]
Russian lawmakers
voted yesterday
to give President Vladimir Putin
the formal approval to use
military force in Ukraine.
Putin said, "The approval came
with approximately
117% of the vote."
Pretty good.
[ Laughter ]
Could've used Wordle
in that punch line.
[ Laughter ]
Sorry. It's hard
to follow a Wordle joke.
President Biden met yesterday
with the Ukrainian
foreign minister.
The meeting wasn't planned.
He just very quickly
decided to move here.
[ Laughter ]
"Any good restaurants?"
In a new episode
of a right-wing podcast,
former President Trump said that
Russian
President Vladimir Putin's
invasion into Ukraine was,
"Genius and wonderful,"
and I got to say,
it's a pretty brilliant way
to make Putin
second-guess himself.
[ Laughter ]
"Who likes plan?
Oh, boy. This is not good.
[ Laughter ]
Genius? Ay, ay, ay."
You -- We fact-checked that,
right?
We fact-checked that Putin, when
he's upset, says "ay, ay, ay"?
[ Laughter ]
I don't want to be out here
looking like a -- Alright.
According to a new report
published in
The New York Times Magazine,
an aide to former
President Trump
described a 2019
White House meeting
with Supreme Court Justice
Clarence Thomas' wife, Ginni,
as being so crazy that Trump
"tried to reign it in."
Whoa, you know things are bad
when Trump is the one
trying to keep things on track.
That's like Bruce Willis
telling the director,
"I feel like this movie
has some plot holes."
[ Laughter ]
During a lunch
in Kentucky yesterday,
Senate Minority Leader
Mitch McConnell
said that President Biden is
a "thoroughly decent
human being."
Added McConnell,
"And if it wasn't for that,
we'd probably get along great."
[ Laughter ]
And finally, a Florida attorney
was recently arrested
after she allegedly stripped
naked in a bar
when they refused to serve her
because she was too drunk.
And she must be
an amazing lawyer,
because she still talked them
into a scotch and soda.
[ Laughter ]
♪♪
In the wake of Russian President
Vladimir Putin's invasion
of Ukraine, President Biden
today announced the full scope
of sanctions against Russia,
including blocks
on Russian banks that hold
$1 trillion in assets
and their ability to do
business in dollars, Euros,
pounds, and the yen.
Which explains why Russia just
tried to buy a fighter jet
with a picture of a bored ape.
[ Laughter ]
[ Russian accent ]
Is good for one jet, no?
[ Normal voice ] Russian
President Vladimir Putin
declared war last night against
Ukraine, and this is nice,
Trump offered to host
the after-party.
That's right,
Vladimir Putin declared war
last night against Ukraine
but said that Russia
has no plans to, "occupy."
Oh, buddy,
nobody has plans to occupy.
We all remember when our war
in Iraq was supposed to
be a three-day weekend.
You're like that guy who thinks
he is going to have one drink
with his old college friends --
No!
You're going to wake up at dawn
in a karaoke booth
with your socks on your hands,
saying,
"Oh, man, did I do
'Islands in the Stream'
with sock puppets?"
[ Laughter ]
After President Biden imposed
an initial round of sanctions
against Russia, the Russian
Foreign Affairs Ministry warned,
"There should be no doubt that
sanctions will receive
a strong response." Come on.
You think you can attack us?
This is America.
We attack ourselves.
We good.
Following last night's Russian
invasion of Ukraine,
the price of oil has jumped
to above $100 a barrel,
for the first time since 2014.
And I'm the second person
to tell you that,
if your friend has a Tesla.
[ Laughter ]
According to new study,
the erectile dysfunction drug
Viagra can be used as a new
treatment for dogs
with a rare eating disorder.
Though it's not going to help
with the embarrassment
at the pharmacy.
It's for my dog!
An eating disorder.
Well, it's rare. So you wouldn't
have heard of it.
And finally actor
Leonardo DiCaprio announced
this week that he has made
a significant investment
in a 110-year-old
champagne house.
Not his first choice.
But it's hard to find
a 24-year-old champagne house.
♪♪
[ Cheering, whistling,
and applause ]